je te donne ta tablette enfin ça c'est
le support que papa fabriqué pour lui
éviter de trop baisser la tête on en
parle peu lors de cette crise sanitaire
les personnes handicapées leurs
difficultés depuis le confinement
isabelle olivier et la merde anaïs 9 ans
et demi elle a eu un accident à la
naissance en fait elle souffre de
paralysie cérébrale
elle a eu un manque d'oxygène qui a
provoqué la pas réalisé de ses quatre
membres les jambes les bras et elle a
aussi un problème au niveau de la parole
puisqu'elle a des difficultés à
articuler habituellement entouré d'une
équipe spécialisée anaïs est désormais
toute la journée à la maison depuis ses
deux ans anaïs fait des stages de
rééducation à l'étranger grâce aux dons
récoltés mais avec le coronavirus les
manifestations ont été annulées
les fonds servent aussi pour le matériel
médical nécessaire et les travaux
adaptés pour anaïs ici on ya fait une
salle de bains une douche à l'italienne
avec des vitres a pour que je puisse la
douche et s'en sont même mouillé ça
c'est sa chambre et cesser son lit
médicalisé qu'est la seule chose que
l'on a pu avoir en location anaïs 9 ans
et demi s'intéresse à beaucoup de choses
de son âge mais pour cette mère de
famille c'est une éducation différente
avec beaucoup de frais à sa charge le
fauteuil de douche lui coûtait 1 900
euros et le siège modulable 6000 euros
en fait la mdph nous a remboursé zéro
euro pour récolter des fonds il a bel
olivier a créé l'association analyse du
rêve à l'esport en janvier 2017
elle est investie également dans le
collectif andy actifs france
si on avait paré culte et réussi à
récolter tous ces fonds je serais
vraiment enfin complètement déprimé oui
abandonné abandonnés par l'état ça c'est
sûr anaïs on va faire l'orthophonie
d'accord avec le confinement tout est à
distance à l'aide de s'assurer de son
clavier adapté cet exercice ludique
permet de pousser anaïs à faire un
maximum de phrases mais sur ok pendant
le confinement toutes les séances de
rééducation d'anaïs ont été arrêtés la
petite fille a perdu en motricité
pendant ces six semaines
c'est vrai qu' on aurait aimé quelqu'un
vienne à domicile pour pour lui donner
des séances mais malheureusement elle
n'en a pas eu
les parents d'anaïs ont dû prendre le
relais et ont pratiqué des séances de
tabata par visio l'arrêt des soins a eu
de lourdes conséquences
isabelle olivier a eu plusieurs
casquettes pendant ce confinement mère
de famille professeur éducatrice elle
alerte sur les conditions des aidants ça
demande beaucoup de temps il fallait
aussi en même temps faire à manger faire
le ménage faire les courses
et en plus les
les activités que l'on a l'habitude de
faire en tant qu'aidant anaïs pèse 30 kg
donc elle est assez lourde à manipuler
et là depuis un an je fais des
tendinites chroniques comme vous pouvez
le voir j'ai une ceinture lombaire parce
que j'ai mal au dos donc oui c'est à ça
a été vraiment une épreuve avec le
collectif andy actifs france elles
demandent à l'état que tous les parents
ayant gardé sans relais leur enfant
handicapé pendant le confinement puisse
toucher à eux aussi une prime d'urgence
de 1500 euros